supposed to be running right now but  let's not talk about this so I was  curious what does internalized misogyny  mean misogyny is the hatred contempt or  prejudice against women or girls women  who experience and terminalized misogyny  May express it through minimizing the  value of women mistrusting women and  believing gender based in the favor of  men but the crazy thing is  I love women like the whole reason I  started my platform was to talk to women  a lot of times girls say things and they  don't realize it's like offensive  there's a girl in my show that said she  dated a dude that was five seven right  and another girl says oh girl you were  doing charity work and I said okay let's  flip it a dude who dates a fat girl is  doing charity work is that okay  I want all the benefits of being a girl  but can't take it back when the men give  it back  so  laughs